GET MUCH TOUGHER IN THIS WAR ON
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU SINCE 2007 AND 2008 THAT
LITERALLY WE HAVE FAKE NEWS
OPERATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
LIBERAL, MAINSTREAM
DESTROY-TRUMP MEDIA.
THEY HAVE A VENDETTA AND THEY'RE
SHOWING IT EVERY DAY.
THEIR NUMBER ONE GOAL IS TO
DAMAGE AND DESTROY THE PRESIDENT
YOU ELECTED AND CLEARLY BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY, AND SPREADING
FAKE NEWS HELPS THEM TO DO THIS.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING IT SINCE '08,
WORSE.
MORE DESTRUCTIVE.
MORE THAN ANYTHING WE COULD HAVE
IMAGINED.
THIS IS NO OUTRIGHT PROPAGANDA
EVERY DAY.
FOR EXAMPLE ON FRIDAY FAKE NEWS
CNN ARE WALL-TO-WALL BREATHLESS
REPORTING ON THE STORY IT TURNS
OUT TO BE A BIG FAT LIE.
THE CLINTON NEWS NETWORK FALSELY
CLAIMED THAT DONALD TRUMP JR.
RECEIVED AN EMAIL ON
SEPTEMBER 4TH 2016 THAT GAVE HIM
SPECIAL ACCESS TO DNC EMAILS
UNFORTUNATELY THE REPORT, AS
THE EMAIL THAT WAS SENT TO
AFTER WIKILEAKS PUT OUT THE DNC
DOCUMENTS.
ABOUT THE TRUMP AND RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THEY CLAIMED THEY HAD NOT ONE
BUT TWO SOURCES VERIFYING THIS
FALSE CLAIM.
CAMPAIGN, OFFERING ACCESS TO
HACKED WIKILEAKS DOCUMENTS.
THEN-CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP,
DONALD TRUMP JR. AND OTHERS IN
THE ORGANIZATION.
THE TIMELINE IS IMPORTANT HERE
BECAUSE ON SEPTEMBER 4TH, THAT
EMAILS BECAME LINKED TO END IT
WAS A MONTH BEFORE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN JOHN PODESTA'S
EMAILS WERE LEAKED BY WIKILEAKS.
>> IF THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
GIVE STOLEN EMAILS -- HACKED
EMAILS TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ACTED ON
IT, YOU WOULD HAVE AN ARGUMENT
THE WAY UNDER NEW YORK LAW.
>> Sean: CRIME, CRIME.
NOT QUITE.
IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG FOR THE REST
OF THE SHEEP IN THE LIBERAL
PRESS LIKE CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC
TO TAKE CNN'S FAKE NEWS AND
SPREAD IT TO THEIR TRUMP-HATING
AUDIENCE.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THE STUFF UP,
WATCH THIS.
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO SENT AN
KEY FOR HACKED WIKILEAKS
DOCUMENTS.
>> THIS WAS ABOUT SEPTEMBER
WIKILEAKS WAS PUTTING OUT SOME
DOCUMENTS, HADN'T PUT OUT OTHER
DOCUMENTS.
REMEMBER THE RUSSIANS HAD HACKED
THE DEMOCRATS IN HAND AT THIS
STUFF OVER TO WIKILEAKS.
WIKILEAKS WAS ESSENTIALLY ACTING
AS AN AGENT OF RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE PUBLISHING HACKED
>> Sean: FAKE NEWS CNN STORY
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP JR. AND
WIKILEAKS, IT WAS A LIE.
IN FACT CNN'S REPORT WAS SO
OUTRAGEOUS OTHER NEWS OUTLETS
STARTED CALLING THEM OUT, EVEN
CNN WAS CAUGHT RED-HANDED.
THEY WERE FORCED TO CORRECT THE
RECORD.
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS THE SAME
CNN, THEY USE THE MODEL -- WE
HAVE A QUESTION TONIGHT FOR THE
HEAD OF CNN, THE CHIEF OF FAKE
WHEN YOUR NETWORK REPEATEDLY
TRIES TO SMEAR AND SLANDER THE
EXTENSION OF THE DNC.
FACTS.
AFTER BEING HUMILIATED ON FRIDAY
AFTER BEING HUMILIATED ON FRIDA
FRIDAY, HE THEN SENT TO
STENOGRAPHER, HUMPTY DUMPTY
BRIAN STELTER TO TRY AND CLEAN
UP THIS WHOLE MESS.
INSTEAD OF PROFUSELY APOLOGIZING
LIKE HE SHOULD HAVE,
HUMPTY DUMPTY TRIED TO USE HIS
NETWORK'S COMPLETE AND UTTER
FAKE NEWS FAILURE TO ATTACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WITH ABC'S SUSPENSION OF A
ROSTER IN THE HEADLINES, I ASKED
CNN IF THERE WOULD BE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST HIM
OR HIS COWRITER.
A SPOKESWOMAN SAID NO.
BECAUSE THE REPORTERS FOLLOWED
CNN STANDARD PROCESS, WHICH
MEANS THAT THE ANONYMOUS SOURCES
THEY WERE USING FOR THE STORY
THE SOURCES HAD BEEN RELIABLE IN
THE PAST.
BUT THEY WERE NOT THIS TIME.
ON FRIDAY NIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
>> REPORTERS, JOURNALISTS MAKE
MISTAKES.
OUR RECORD AS JOURNALISTS IN
COVERING THIS TRUMP STORY AND
RUSSIAN STORY IS PRETTY GOOD.
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO THE
RECORD OF DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
IT'S EVEN PATHETIC BY FAKE CNN
STANDARDS.
EARLIER TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
SCHOOLED ABSOLUTELY           'A
SCHOOLED ABSOLUTELY           'S
SCHOOLED ABSOLUTELY           'L
SCHOOLED ABSOLUTELY           'T
SCHOOLED ABSOLUTELY           'Y
SCHOOLED.
THIS WAS A 101 ON HOW TO BE
COSTA AS HE TRIED TO DEFEND THE
NETWORKS BIASED REPORTING.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT JOURNALISTS
MAKE HONEST MISTAKES AND THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THEM FAKE NEWS.
>> ONE JOURNALIST MAKE HONEST
MISTAKES THEY SAID OWN UP TO
YOU DON'T.
I'M SORRY -- I'M NOT FINISHED.
THERE'S A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MAKING HONEST MISTAKES
AND SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
REGULARLY.
YOU CAN'T SAY -- I'M NOT DONE.
>> COMPLETELY FAKE SARAH.
>> YOU CANNOT SAY THAT IT'S AN
INFORMATION THAT YOU KNOW TO BE
FALSE.
>> Sean: FAKE NEWS CNN ISN'T
ALONE IN SPREADING LIES IN FAKE
NEWS AIMED AT HURTING THE
PRESIDENT.
MISLEADING PHOTO ABOUT THE CROWD
SIZE AT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RALLY
ON FRIDAY.
TURNS OUT THAT IMAGE THAT YOU
TWEETING OUT PHOTOS DURING HIS
SPEECH THAT SHOWED A PACKED
DAVE WEIGLE OVER AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" PUT OUT A
PHONY POST HOURS BEFORE I
ARRIVED AT THE VENUE WITH
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE ON
THEIR WAY IN.
MANY PEOPLE UNABLE TO GET IN.
DEMAND APOLOGY AND RETRACTION
FROM FAKE NEWS
"WASHINGTON POST."
THE PRESIDENT ADDED THIS.
"DAVE WEIGLE OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JUST
ADMITTED HIS PICTURE WAS A FAKE,
A FRAUD SHOWING AN ALMOST EMPTY
ARENA LAST NIGHT.
WHEN IN FACT HE KNEW THE ARENA
THAT PHOTO IS THE PERFECT
COUNTRY ATTEMPT TO EMBARRASS,
INSIGNIFICANT, SUPERFLUOUS
THINGS AT EVERY TURN.
THIS ONE BLEW UP IN THE FAKE
AMOUNT BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
REFUSES TO SIT BACK AND LET THE
MEDIA SPREAD LIES STAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
BUT FOR THE PRESS IN THIS
COUNTRY, NOTHING IS TOO SMALL
AND TOO PETTY.
THEY WILL LITERALLY ATTEMPT TO
USE ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE
BATTLE FOR SELF-PRESERVATION."
THE TIMES, THE SO-CALLED
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING OVER
THERE INCLUDES EXPLOSIVE
INFORMATION THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS UP TO 12 DIET COKES A DAY.
THAT'S PRETTY LAUGHABLE.
RIGHT UP THERE WITH CNN'S TWO
SCOOPS OF ICE CREAM FOR HIM AND
ONLY ONE FOR HIS GUESTS.
ANOTHER BOMBSHELL REPORT CLAIMS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WATCHES UP TO
EIGHT HOURS OF ELEVATION TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHTFULLY
IN THE FAILING "NEW YORK TIMES"
WRONG.
ALSO, I SELDOM, IF EVER, WATCH
CNN OR MSNBC, BOTH OF WHICH I
CONSIDER FAKE NEWS.
I NEVER WATCHED ON LEMON, WHO I
ONCE CALLED THE DUMBEST MAN ON
THE MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY HAS A
MASSIVE CREDIBILITY CRISIS.
LOOK AT THE HEADLINE.
46% THINK THE MEDIA MAKE UP
STORIES ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T TRUST
THE MEDIA ANYMORE AND NOR SHOULD
THEY.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY, REGULARLY PEDDLING
AN AGENDA AND FAKE NEWS.
HERE'S ANOTHER COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
LAST WEEK BOTH BLOOMBERG AND
REUTERS RAN WILD WITH THAT STORY
CLAIMING THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER'S TEAM
SUBPOENAED PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS FAMILY'S BANK RECORDS FROM
DEUTSCHE BANK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
SHOT DOWN THOSE MURMURS AND
AGAIN.
AND ISSUED CORRECTIONS.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S BAD, LAST
WEEK ABC NEWS' BRIAN ROSS.
MONTH HE CLAIMED THAT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN WAS
PREPARED TO TESTIFY THAT
CANDIDATE TRUMP ORDERED HIM TO
CONTACT THE RUSSIANS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT CERTAINLY WOULD SEEM TO
SUGGEST THAT MICHAEL FLYNN HAD A
FAIR AMOUNT OF INFORMATION TO
OFFER THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IN
RETURN.
TEAM.
OF THE TRUMP FAMILY AND OTHERS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE'S PREPARED TO TESTIFY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A CANDIDATE,
ALL THAT HE SAID AT THIS POINT.
>> Sean: HOURS LATER BRIAN
ROSS WAS FORCED TO ADMIT THAT HE
WAS COMPLETELY WRONG AND HE
ATTEMPTED TO CORRECT THE RECORD
YET AGAIN.
THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC.
WATCH THIS.
>> A CLARIFICATION TONIGHT ON
SOMETHING ONE OF THE CONFIDANTES
TOLD US AND IT WE REPORTED
EARLIER TODAY.
HE SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED
FLYNN TO CONTACT THEM DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
HE'S NOW CLARIFYING THAT SAYING
THAT CANDIDATE TRUMP ASKED HIM
DURING THE CAMPAIGN TO FIND WAYS
TO REPAIR RELATIONS WITH RUSSIA
AND OTHER.
AFTER THE ELECTION THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT ASKED HIM --
TOLD HIM TO CONTACT HIM ON
ISSUES INCLUDING WORKING
TOGETHER TO FIGHT ISIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHOCKING.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BRIAN ROSS'S
ORIGINAL REPORT AND WHAT
FOUR WEEKS WITHOUT PAY AND HE'S
BEEN BANNED FROM REPORTING NOW
ON THE PRESIDENT IN THE FUTURE.
YOU WOULD THINK WITH ALL THESE
FAKE NEWS EMBARRASSMENTS THAT
MAY BE THE MEDIA WOULD END THIS
HYSTERICAL AND RECKLESS ONGOING
DAILY REPORTING OF THE PRESIDENT
AND MAYBE JUST FOCUS ON FACTS
AND TRYING TO GET IT RIGHT,
HERE'S THE THING.
SPREADING MORE LIES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP SINCE THE MINUTE HE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS NOW TAKEN A
POINT OF ALMOST ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING
FAKE NEWS.
GLENN GREENWALD FROM THE
INTERCEPT SUMS IT UP PERFECTLY
WITH THIS HEADLINE.
AGES, NOW REFUSES ALL
TRANSPARENCY OVER WHAT HAPPENED.
THE MEDIA'S HATRED FOR THE
PRESIDENT IS SO PROFOUND AND SO
EXTREME THAT NOTHING ELSE
MATTERS TO THEM.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THEY DON'T CARE OR BEING FAIR OR
BEING BALANCED, NOT BIAS.
BY THE WAY, WE'VE BEEN SAYING
THAT THE PRESS IS FIXATED ON
TAKING THIS PRESIDENT DOWN.
I BELIEVE THAT TO BE TRUE.
THAT'S THEIR SHARED MISSION.
A CONCERTED EFFORT AND A STAIN
ON AMERICA.
AND IN THAT SENSE THE
PRESIDENT'S RIGHT.
MEMBERS OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
THEY ARE RIGID, THEIR RADICAL
THEY ARE NOT JOURNALISTS.
THE PRESS GOT CAUGHT COLLUDED
WITH HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
CAMPAIGN AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO INFLICT
MAXIMUM DAMAGE ON THE PRESIDENT
YOU ELECTED REGARDLESS OF
PROVES ALL OF THIS.
THE TRUTH, FACTS DON'T MATTER TO
THE MEDIA.
LET ME PUT IT MORE SIMPLY.
THEY ARE MORALLY BANKRUPT.
THEY HAVE AN AGENDA.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH.
THE AGENDA IS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY'S AGENDA, THE CLINTON'S
AGENDA.
AS A RESULT THE PRESS HAS NOW